depression is a very serious clinical
problem the work has been going on for
many years to discover better treatments
for depression most depression
treatments medicine I'm talking about
take weeks to months to work like Prozac
and paxil and so that's been a problem
in that day there's a delay and they
also don't work in everybody so my
research team has been working for many
years to discover better treatments
better medicine treatments for
depression and we have recently found
that ketamine is a rapidly acting
antidepressant now some people know
ketamine as a recreational drug of abuse
called Special K but we have found that
it has potential for the treatment of
depression that has not responded to
traditional antidepressant treatments
and that it works faster that it can
work within several hours so we're
working on it it's not yet approved so
it's now at the level of research but
it's now been found at by research
groups all over the world that ketamine
works quickly and that the response can
at least be maintained for several weeks
so now we're working on how to maintain
the response for much longer than that
and to test out its safety for long-term
treatment but at a minimum it's broken
new ground because ketamine works
differently than other antidepressants
and we now know that there are methods
that get people better from serious
forms of depression very quickly one
reason that scientists say that the
ketamine findings are a major advance in
the treatment of depression is that
ketamine works very differently than
other antidepressants the
antidepressants that are now generally
available work through mono means
neurotransmitters like serotonin
and norepinephrine that's how Prozac and
paxil and zola for example work they
they block the reuptake of the
neurotransmitter serotonin ketamine does
not work through that mechanism ketamine
works through another neurotransmitter
system called the glutamate system and
initially its effects are modulated by
blocking the NMDA glutamate receptor so
we know that's part of the way that
ketamine works but researchers now in
labs around the world are probing more
deeply about how ketamine can start by
working through the glutamate system and
then cause other changes in brain
function that result in that
antidepressant response so that that is
work that is now occurring but we do
know it as a minimum that it works very
differently than the available
antidepressants as I mentioned ketamine
is a recreational drug of abuse and we
have to be concerned about that in any
development of ketamine that leads to
formal approval by the FDA and
ultimately becomes generally available
for the treatment of depression so the
clinical studies that are now being
undertaken by a major pharmaceutical
company is studying internet you know
intranasal forms of ketamine and they
will watch for any signs of abuse by
patients probably the way ketamine will
be distributed will be on a dose by dose
basis and that for patients that have a
history of substance abuse it may not be
the appropriate drug you know to use but
I personally feel that ketamine is well
tolerated in the dose that we use for
the treatment of depression and that if
longer-term studies show that it's safe
and that it's not abused it could really
revolutionize the treatment of
depression for
patients who have serious depression
that is treatment resistant to the
available treatments so it will be used
for a very certain group of people who
are really suffering